Today,
I want to tell you three stories from my
life at that time offered perhaps the
best calligraphy instruction in the
country throughout the campus.
Every poster,
every label on every drawer was
beautifully hand calligraphic because I
had dropped out and didn't have to take
the normal classes.
I decided to take a calligraphy class to
learn how to do this.
None of this had even a hope of any
practical application in my life,
but 10 years later when we were
designing the first macintosh computer,
it all came back to me and we designed
it all into the Mac.
It was the first computer with beautiful
typography.
Of course,
it was impossible to connect the dots
looking forward when I was in college,
but it was very,
very clear.
Looking backwards.
Ten years later,
again,
you can't connect the dots looking
forward.
You can only connect them looking
backwards so you have to trust that the
dots will somehow connect in your
future.
You have to trust in something,
your gut destiny,
life,
Karma,
whatever was.
And I started apple in my parents garage
when I was 20.
We worked hard and in 10 years apple had
grown from just the two of us in the
garage into a $2,000,000,000
company with over 4,000
employees.
We just released our finest creation,
the macintosh a year earlier,
and I just turned 30 and then I got
fired,
but something slowly began to dawn on
me.
I still loved what I did.
I've been rejected,
but I was still in love and so I decided
to start over.
The heaviness of being successful was
replaced by the lightness of being a
beginner,
again,
less sure about everything.
During the next five years,
I started a company named next,
another company named Pixar.
Pixar went on to create the world's
first computer animated feature film and
is now the most successful animation
studio in the world.
I'm convinced that the only thing that
kept me going was that I loved what I
did.
You got to find what you love and the
only way to be truly satisfied is to do
what you believe is great work,
and the only way to do great work is to
love what you do.
If you haven't found it yet,
keep looking and don't settle.
Your time is limited,
so don't waste it living someone else's
life.
Don't let the noise of other's opinions
drowned out your own inner voice and
most important,
have the courage to follow your heart
and intuition.
They somehow already know what you truly
want to do.